[Music]
hi everyone my name is dr madhu shetty
i'm a board-certified radiation
oncologist practicing in the san
francisco east bay prior to coming to
the gsb
when i have been taking care of patients
i have noticed that many of my patients
experienced many of the problems that i
experienced growing up my patients had
language barriers transportation
barriers cultural barriers
and oftentimes when they would seek care
they were afraid that they were not
going to get the best care or they were
not going to be treated as well as
others
my team and i strove to make sure that
every patient walking in our door
felt respected
and we gave them the best possible care
with them as a partner in every step of
the process
unfortunately the financial realities of
our hospital system
were such that we ended up closing the
hospital and our community
really is the one who felt the loss
i came to gsb with the intention of
gaining formal business skills so that i
could help
other communities
keep their health care systems in place
so that individuals could get good high
quality care close to home with all the
support that they already have built in
during a very challenging time in their
life
and as i've been at gsb taking classes
from all disciplines i started to take
entrepreneurship classes and then i
became an accidental entrepreneur
one of the big challenges that i've seen
for patients undergoing radiation or
chemotherapy is that they developed
significant hair loss their face can
develop significant ashy or pale dry
looks and their fingernails can turn
black and their fingers and toes can
develop severe numbness
tingling sensations and swelling
you know until you experience some of
these symptoms
one does not realize how much it impacts
our life and particularly our emotional
well-being
what we don't talk about is the other
symptoms that you just can't see because
they're covered up so many of my
patients who are undergoing radiation to
the breast will have significant redness
pinkness it's appealing a burning and a
weeping of the tissue
oftentimes it can feel like the worst
sunburn of their they've ever had in
life
some of my patients have been so
devastated in the process both
physically and emotionally of their
cancer diagnosis that they have actually
become suicidal
and that's where it becomes so important
to have
a team taking care of one to give you
all the support both physically and
emotionally to get through that time
as i researched different products to
help my patients i never could find
anything i really liked
even products that are labeled as
organic natural or clean
oftentimes have ingredients that can be
harmful to patients during the process
and it can be that the ingredient can
trigger a migraine or nausea or it could
be that the ingredients interact at the
skin and can actually cause worsening of
skin irritation and in the very worst
case it can actually block some of the
pathways for the chemore radiation which
will make it ultimately ineffective at
curing your cancer
so it's very important that patients be
able to get the correct information
about the products that they're spending
so much time and money to purchase and
understand
is it a product that will help them or
is it a product that will hurt them
and that led to the process of starting
my company balmier skin
so that i could make sure we could get
high quality products to patients
as they were on this journey i could not
have done this process without
the support of my classmates from my
teachers and from gsb alumni who have
given me feedback on what i could do
context for how i could execute faster
or the or the resources of
how do i launch a company how do i hire
individuals every step of that journey
requires special skills
and the entire gsb community has
supported my vision and helped me to be
able to execute in that process
i'm eternally grateful for everything
each member of the gsb community has
done to help me in the process to
fulfill my mission
so i urge you to think about gsb in your
future career plans if you're an
entrepreneur this is awesome place to be
and if you're not an entrepreneur
and you wanted to go into other avenues
you very much well might become an
accidental entrepreneur like myself
thank you so much
[Music]
you